Here are our equations again for the mean and the variance.
They should now look very familiar.
The problem with that is they require two passes through the data.
First, I have to go through all the data and compute the mean.
I do this by summing up all the data and dividing it by the total number of data items.
For that, I maintain two things.
I maintain the total number of data items, which I increment every time I see a new item.
I maintain the sum of all Xᵢs, which I can easily add up as I go through the data.
Once I've done this, I know µ, and then I can finally plug it in here,
but now I have to go through the data again and compute this guy,
so we can finally get to my covariance.
Now, I want to teach you a trick now for which we don't maintain this guy
but instead maintain just this guy.
The nice thing about this is if you maintain these three things you only need a single pass.
To see, as we go through the data, we can maintain the number of data items that we have.
We can maintain the sum over here.
We can maintain the sum of the data themselves.
You can maintain simultaneously the sum of the square of the data items,
but it's not obvious that from these three things alone
you can figure out what σ² is.
Let's play a game.
The way the game works is that I put a number of mathematical expressions here on the  right side.
I'll start the derivation and leave little gaps and ask you to pick one of those
and plug it into the equation.
You can only use each of those ones but you won't use all of them, just a subset.
Let me do the first step by hand and rewrite σ² by factoring out the square.
I can rewrite this by multiplying things out.
So, help me. What do you think goes in the middle?
Which of those expressions?